Water
earth
fire
air
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my video for the new avatar the
last airbender announcement for all the multiple
new series and new avatar movies so i'll explain
what's going on what they're gonna start with
what's happening first and when we're actually
gonna see all those new projects if you're new to
the channel of course i'll be doing episode videos
and videos for all the movies that they're doing
there's going to be so much new avatar content
coming from them animated avatar content so it's
literally the best possible thing that could have
happened you said you wanted a new animated
avatar series mike bryan and nickelodeon are
like hold our beers we'll do you one better we're
going to give you a brand new avatar verse with a
bunch of new shows and a bunch of new movies so
first things first just explaining what happened
if you didn't see the big presentation that they
were doing yesterday viacom is rolling out a brand
new streaming service called paramount plus and
they were announcing their programming slate like
there was a big disney plus announcement with all
the new star wars shows the new marvel shows that
they're doing it was enormous they're doing
like 10 new marvel shows and 10 new star wars
shows in the next couple of years alone so the
viacom people are like okay how do we get people
to pay for our service so they were announcing
all their new programming and when they got to
the part where they were announcing all the
new nickelodeon animation shows and movies
that they're developing they announced that mike
and bryant are creating their own studio called
avatar studios for the purposes of going full
star wars or like full marvel cinematic universe
with the avatar the last airbender brand so this
is all for animation they said they'll be making
multiple new animated avatar series at this studio
animated movies and shorts for paramount plus the
streaming service theatrical movies like the demon
slayer movie or the my hero academia movies or
like even pixar movies they'll actually release
those in theaters when we can go back to theaters
and some of their new avatar stuff will
also be going back to the regular old
school nickelodeon tv channels remember when
cable tv was the thing that people paid for
most of the bigger series and movies though
that they make will eventually all live
on paramount plus including the original avatar
the last airbender series in the quora episodes
i know you're all asking what does this mean about
the netflix avatar the last airbender live action
series that they were doing last year that they
left that project netflix is still making that
i'll explain how all these new avatar series and
movies will affect that netflix stuff later in
the video but they announced that the first new
project that they're doing this first new avatar
project is going to be an animated theatrical
film they'll release it in theaters and it'll
begin production later this year this is mike and
Bryan's official statement so bryan posted this on
his instagram he said brick is back at nickelodeon
in a big way with a bunch of emojis mike and i are
heading up a new studio dedicated to expanding the
avatar verse so it lets him saying that they're
creating their own version of the marvel cinematic
universe with the avatar characters basically like
we're expanding the mythology in a huge way with
a bunch of new series and a bunch of new movies
so even though we're kind of only thinking about
the next couple years i can't wait to see that
next series they're thinking about the next 15 to
20 years of avatar like some of you will all go
on to have children and grandchildren who will be
watching brand new avatar series like i said this
is like the coolest possible thing that could have
happened to them them saying that they weren't
really hot on creating more avatar content right
now viacom and nickelodeon backing up a dump truck
to their house and saying why don't we just give
you your own studio to do whatever you want to do
what do we have here then their statement just
goes on to say it's hard to believe it's been
19 years since we created avatar the last
airbender but even after all this time there
are still so many stories and so many time periods
in aang's world that we are eager to bring to life
meaning that a lot of the new series will just
jump around in the timeline in the past and
probably in the future as well we are fortunate to
have an ever-growing community of passionate fans
that enjoys exploring the avatar verse as much as
we do just for example last year when avatar the
last airbender episodes hit netflix it was the
most popular animated series around the world
of any kind it beat all the brand new animation
it was that popular and this is in 2020 so you
have all these brand new kids and people that are
discovering the series after all this time so it
is more popular than ever right now then they go
on to say and with this new avatar studios venture
we have an unparalleled opportunity to develop our
franchise and its storytelling on a vast scale in
a myriad of exciting ways and mediums that just
means that they're going to continue to do all
the books and the comics alongside all the brand
new series and movies and shorts that they're
going to be doing then they thank the viacom and
nickelodeon executives for allowing them to do
this saying from the start they've supported our
ambitious plans and created a positive proactive
environment for us that's them throwing a little
bit of shade at netflix because they're still a
little bit salty about what happened with the
netflix avatar the last airbender live action
project they say we're excited to be back at
nickelodeon where avatar began doing what we
do best in the biggest way possible we can't wait
to build great teams and productions to make all
this fantasy a reality like i said they're not
going to be staffing up and starting production
on that first new avatar movie till later this
year so they're still kind of spinning up the
development process right now so a lot of you are
now asking when are they going to release this
first new avatar the last airbender movie that
they're talking about and what is the movie going
to be about well they said in the announcement
that they wouldn't be stepping up and begin
production until later this year it typically
takes three to four years to make animated movies
just depending on how big they are spider-man
into the spider-verse is a really great example
amazing movie but it was so complex that it took
them four years from start to finish to make that
but that's the extreme example the avatar the
last airbender movie that they're making will
probably be something closer to like the demon
slayer movie or the my hero academia movies just a
little bit smaller so they might be able to get it
out by summer 2023 or a little bit after that just
depending on how production goes but it's still
bare minimum gonna be a couple years before we
see that what's most likely though is that they'll
announce what the movie is going to be about later
this year like here this is gonna be the movie
then within a year that will get our first trailer
then we'll actually see the movie within a couple
years then what happens after that movie comes out
per the announcement that's when we see the first
new full-blown animated avatar series so they're
kind of doing one thing at a time right now but
eventually they'll get to the point where they
can do multiple series and multiple movies all at
the same time just the exact same way that marvel
does all their projects like we have the marvel
disney plus series happening right now but they're
also in the middle of making a bunch of marvel
movies here's the thing for everyone asking what
the movie's gonna be about though what is this
first new series going to be about which avatar
is it going to follow but mike and bryan said that
they felt like the original animated avatar the
last airbender series had a perfect ending as
it is right now and they had zero interest in
trampling on that by trying to turn any of those
comic book stories into new series so the avatar
the last airbender movie that they're working on
right now probably isn't going to be a retelling
of the original story and it's probably
not going to be based on any of the comics
yes it's totally possible they could do a movie
about older adult team eng like we saw them during
the events of the legend of korra flashbacks with
the really old versions of their characters but i
think it's more likely just given their mo with
the way they've treated the avatar franchise in
the past that their strategy would be to start
fresh with a brand new avatar that they haven't
done a big series for before like avatar kyoshi
or a truly brand new avatar character that we've
never seen before they're also probably going
to use this first new avatar movie to introduce
a brand new animation style as well like cora
looked very different on an animation perspective
from the original avatar series the beginnings arc
those two episodes could have been like its own
small movie by itself they did a completely unique
animation style from the other core episodes just
to differentiate it but that is probably what
they'll do they'll do the movie to introduce
that new avatar character then their first new
avatar series will just follow that brand new
avatar they introduced during the movie like brand
new earthbender avatar who isn't kioshi shows up
in the movie they have some really big battles
some really big villain that they fight during
the movie then when they get to that first new
series is just avatar the legend of whoever that
person was for four seasons here's the thing
though for everyone who wants your cabbage man
series or an iro series or a futuristic cyberpunk
avatar series set in the far future like blade
runner avatar mike and bryan said that they will
do multiple new series and multiple new animated
movies so anything you really want any of your
big theories within reason they can eventually
get to all those different stories in the next 10
to 15 years like i said this new avatar studios
deal really is like them creating their own marvel
studios the animated shorts that they talk about
are probably just to fill the gaps in between
just because it's so much easier for them to
produce those and get them out quicker like it'll
take years to develop this brand new avatar movie
in the new avatar series but the shorts they
can get out in under a year easily the way mike
and bryan say it they're just so many different
points in the timeline that they love to explore
they're just going to be jumping around in the
timeline quite a bit but for those of you asking
how this all affects the netflix live-action
avatar the last airbender project so they left
the project last year but netflix is still making
that so this is still coming out which is why
it's probably less likely that this new avatar
the last airbender movie will be about team aang
there's probably some contractual arrangements
behind the scenes saying that they won't try to
directly compete with netflix series so if netflix
were trying to do a ang series and then mike and
bryan tried to do an animated teaming series
they would probably be a big lawsuit in viacom
netflix probably don't want that to happen so
that's why whatever this brand new avatar project
the new movie the new series is going to be it'll
be somebody completely new some new avatar we've
never heard about before but they'll announce
more details about what all these new projects
are going to be later this year so of course
i'll do videos for that and other bonus videos
leave all your requests and your big questions
in the comments below if you weren't around for
my channel way back in the day i did episode
videos for all of cora and i have a bunch of
avatar the last airbender videos as well so i'll
put links for all that stuff in the description
but my full Wandavision episode 8 video will post
next tomorrow on friday make sure you have alerts
enabled so you don't miss any of that everyone
click here for that brand new spider-man 3 no
way home teaser trailer video and click here
for my brand new Wandavision episode 8 trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!